you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
primark promises to make sustainable
clothing that's affordable for all but
is that enough to fix fast fashion
more than 70 arrests made after climate
activists caused chaos on the m25 for
the second time this week
and the magic of mushrooms the company
that's come up with a new solution for
insulating homes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions
now primark has promised to make all of
its clothes using recycled or more
sustainably sourced material by the end
of the decade the retailer says that the
change won't lead to higher prices and
instead items will be more durable but
our pledges on sustainable clothing
enough well let's just take a look at
the scale of the problem the fashion
industry is responsible for around 10
of the world's carbon emissions textile
production alone contributes 1.2 billion
tons of co2 every year that is more than
the carbon footprint of international
flights and shipping combined and it's
estimated that one and a half trillion
liters of water is used by the industry
a year with up to 20 000 liters of water
needed to produce just one kilogram of
cotton
and in the uk the fast fashion industry
contributes to the 140 million pounds of
wearable clothes that go to landfill
every year
for many it's the go-to shop for
affordable fashion and primark wants to
become more environmentally friendly
without being more expensive
by 2030 the company aims to use only
recycled or sustainably sourced
materials and halve the emissions it
produces
the level of ambition in these
statements is fantastic but we really
need to see the detail and the society
is demanding that these companies no
longer just pay lip service to the idea
of a low-carbon society that they really
actually make these reductions primock
says it's going to make clothes that
last longer to reduce waste campaigners
say that must come at a price
we asked shoppers in manchester whether
they'd pay more in the name of
sustainability sure if the quality
matches the price yeah we're students
and like
um we're on a bit of a budget so like it
needs to be affordable for us as well if
i can get you for cheap and i like it
like this high fashion then i don't
really bother where it comes from as
long as it
looks good on you
at beaumont organic they strive to make
trendy clothes without following
fleeting trends we are very slow fashion
we only produce two seasons a year and
there's quite limited
styles and stock within that it's about
limiting waste and because that's a very
big issue within the fashion industry
is excess stock at the end of the season
they use recycled and organic materials
so they don't rely on harmful pesticides
to grow their cotton and they say their
clothes can last for decades but you
won't find anything in this shop for
less than 50 pounds that's a lot of
money for many people
setting ambitious sustainability targets
is one thing meeting them is another and
if the talk is of buying less to last
longer staying profitable and ethical
could be a fine balance becky cottrell
sky news manchester
we'll be discussing whether the fashion
industry is doing enough to become more
sustainable in our daily climate show
debate and today i'm joined by founder
and managing director of seahorse
environmental isabella gornall and dame
julia king baroness brown of cambridge
chair of the carbon trust and member of
the house of lords that's coming up for
you in just a few moments time now in
some of today's other climate news a
fire at a national grid site has shut
down an interconnector power cable
linking electricity supplies between the
uk and france the national grid has
issued a statement saying there
currently is a sufficient buffer of
spare capacity to operate the
electricity system securely over this
evening's peak demand period
the government has announced the winners
of a 23 million pound competition to
help international shipping reach net
zero by
but shipping leaders called the funding
a drop in the ocean in an open letter to
the chancellor and say that the
government must co-invest one billion
pounds to decarbonize the sector
transport secretary grant shaps had this
to say about the letter
although a billion pounds is a huge
amount of money when you take that
in the round of what it costs to build
ships
and the sector as a whole that kind of
money flows in uh pretty regularly from
the private sector now the government
and i can't preempt what the chancellor
will say at the spending review but the
government will do its part in leading
this industry we want absolute zero by
2050 in maritime so that's not just
about money it's about making sure that
we get the right diplomatic backdrop to
all of this as well
now the 2019 to 2020 australian
wildfires released more than twice as
much carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
than previously thought that's according
to a study published in nature and a
separate paper has found that the smoke
from those fires traveled thousands of
miles before settling on the water
triggering a phytoplankton bloom bigger
than australia itself scientists say
that the findings highlight the complex
links between wildfires and ecosystems
and today is the 50th anniversary of
greenpeace beginning environmental
campaigning the movement started when a
ship carrying a group of activists left
canada for a small island off the coast
of alaska in an attempt to stop the u.s
government testing nuclear devices or
greenpeace say that its goals in 2021
include stopping new fossil fuel
projects and making green recovery fair
for everyone
now more than 70 people have been
arrested after climate protesters
blocked parts of the m25 for a second
time this week motorists faced long
delays while activists sat on the roads
stopping traffic in hertfordshire and
surrey to demand government action on
home insulation our correspondent ender
brady has more
but this was the second time in three
days this week that climate change
protesters have caused chaos on
britain's busiest motorway the m25 on
monday there were a total of 98 people
arrested and many of them have been
arrested again today this time around
they targeted three separate junctions
of the m25 one at darford and kent one
at ryegade and leatherhead in surrey
and one near here at south mims service
station on the northern section of the
motorway they're from a group calling
themselves insulate britain and their
bottom line is they want the government
to do more in terms of insulating social
housing across the united kingdom so
dozens and dozens more arrests what the
group did was
they glued themselves to the road the
slipways off the m25 it took dozens and
dozens of police officers
hours to safely remove them and then
arrest them so this is the second time
in three days now the activists have
apologized to motorists there was some
social media postings people will have
seen videos of very angry confrontations
between drivers and the protesters but
the activists have said
that they
feel very very bad about what they've
been doing but they say it's absolutely
vital for their campaign and i think the
big worry is that two days out of three
this week they've done this could there
be more planned
now when you think of insulation in your
home an image of rolls of fiberglass
materials possibly comes to mind but one
company wants to change that for
mushrooms biome is using nature-based
sustainable materials to revolutionize
the construction industry and here is
their story
[Music]
i found that there were huge amounts of
waste coming out of the construction
industry so i developed a construction
system and then we realized there was a
major problem around the materials in
the industry and therefore we started to
focus on developing our own materials
there have been a lot of challenges
there's been a lot of resistance from
the industry there's been a huge kind of
perception barrier around natural
materials and the stigma that surrounds
them not being able to perform as well
as synthetic materials but when we
started testing against accreditation
standards we realized that we're
actually outperforming the synthetic
materials and that really created that
shift and mindset
the climate crisis is um you know one of
the biggest existential challenges uh
that we've ever come across as a species
and so
for us to continue to grow we have to
have a positive impact we can no longer
just be sustainable or have a kind of
carbon neutral approach um we need to go
beyond that and we need to look at
carbon negative approaches and where's
ways in which we can always add value
and have a positive and regenerative
impact on the environment and society
with all of our practices
well do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by the founder and
managing director of seahorse
environmental isabella gornall and dame
julia king baroness brown of cambridge
who is chair of the carbon trust and
member of the house of lords we're going
to be discussing how the government
should be taking more action on climate
change plus are those pledges on
sustainable clothing that we heard
enough to make the fashion industry more
eco-friendly
[Music]
i've been involved with waterway since
around 2016 and we all went to a few of
us went to mozambique in 2017 to
highlight the the problems that that
people in the developing countries have
with the lack of clean water and i
i saw firsthand the the amazing work
that water will do in providing clean
water not just clean water but the
resources and the
all the things that people need in order
to to maintain and
and have clean water in these
communities and the year after i went
there there was
a big drought in mozambique and then the
year after that there was a flood so
climate change seems to affect the
poorest countries the most and so i
guess this this campaign is about
highlighting the need for funds that the
developing countries need we're asking
for a third of the uk's climate budget
which in total is about 14 billion
pounds so we're asking for around 4
billion pounds of that to go to the
people in the front line the people that
you can see who are highlighting sort of
i guess
represented in these sculptures
people like like them who need the money
the most in order to to help with the um
with the the climate change and the
effects it has in their communities
i guess it kind of highlights the the
the issues the very real issues that
these people have and the fragility of
water they're created by a company
called ice box and they represent the
communities in colombia malay
and and india as well and burkina faso
so they're beautiful sculptures and it
kind of reminds me of
when i was in mozambique and watching
the women in these communities having to
travel miles in order to get clean water
and the effects that that has in
communities it's kind of a feminist
issue as well if you think about it
because these women are taking out the
communities because they have to spend
most of their time during the day
walking miles and miles and miles to get
clean water and quite often that water
isn't even clean so their children get
sick and it has a huge knock-on effect
so i think that having access to clean
water as a human rights issue
as much as anything else and so you know
this is what watery do they sort of
bring attention to the
you know the issues that these
communities face and how important it is
for people all over the world especially
in developing countries to have access
to clean water
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
thursday looks like being the best day
of the week whilst early mist and fog
gives way to sunny spells and through
the day there'll just be one or two
showers most likely down towards the
southeast temperatures up to 22 degrees
celsius that's 72 degrees fahrenheit
later though we'll find some wet and
windy weather starting to make its way
in from the west while these rather
changeable conditions may not be ideal
but it does mean in terms of air quality
that pollution levels are likely to be
low right across the country
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on the sky news we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day that is with
the founder and managing director of
seahorse environmental isabella gornall
and dame julia king baroness brown of
cambridge who is chair of the carbon
trust and also a member of the house of
lords so good to see you both tonight
the big story of the day of course is
that political reshuffle going on still
going on but from what you have seen as
starting with you isabella um
net are we longer or shorter
environmental champions in in the senior
ranks of government
thank you so much for
having me um i must say i think actually
we've seen a very positive shift with
michael gove going into the deal with
the housing department it's a very big
challenge for the
government right now
especially this this autumn we have been
waiting for the heat and building
strategy for a very long time and i
think that michael is the perfect person
having seen what he did when he was
environment secretary to be able to
actually champion such a tough
issue but also make sure that there's a
strong environmental aspect throughout
that okay so thumbs up there from
isabella for michael gove to housing
what would you say dame julia
um well michael gove would would have
been the one person i would have
highlighted as being uh hopefully a
positive the heaton building strategy of
course is a is a bay's strategy although
one would hope that uh mhclg will have a
a big input to it um one of the things
michael gove has on his desk is of
course the new planning bill um that
will be absolutely crucial and uh the
the version of it that we were going to
see really didn't take environment and
sustainability into account seriously so
i think we can really hope that michael
gove and his team will get behind that
and and make sure that the new
arrangements for planning in the uk
really do deliver low-carbon and
resilient um town cities and
infrastructure so a lot of both of your
hopes riding on michael go there no
pressure there mr gov what about
treasury isabella because we haven't
seen any changes there yet and of course
treasury hold the purse strings don't
they so key to getting the money to
these climate goals
yes exactly we've seen steve
barkley has been moved into the cabinet
office and he was really in charge of
the spending review briefings so the
entire environment sector has spent the
last few months writing all of their
submissions for the spending review and
for the budget hoping to get what they
want in terms of financing for new
environmental and
climate schemes so
let's hope who wherever
replaces him um this week has got a
strong environmental
agenda as we really need to see some
significance spending now in the um
spending
review but also we are waiting for the
net zero
review um which is due out of the
treasury imminently
and that's going to really be a
bellwether for us
in terms of how much
and
ambition the
uk government wishes to set
a head of cop
you've both mentioned um the heat and
building strategy we're still waiting
for it it's been long promised hasn't it
um something else i want to ask you
about is actually a policy that was put
into place um and that was the green
home homes grant um there's another
scheme uh that i was mentioning there
that was actually put into place a lot
of criticism
it attracted would you say dame julia
the green homes grant was it a waste of
money
uh
no and i think it was right to to um to
stop the part of it that the government
did quickly but they obviously hadn't
got um well enough prepared for which
was the the grants to people to
individuals um wanting to install low
carbon heating and and more insulation
but but i think what's been really
really disappointing is how long well
the fact that we still don't have a
replacement for it we still do have the
local authority part of it going on um
which is supporting uh local authority
homes and some um
other community kind of projects that i
think is being very successful we don't
hear very much about that that needs
more more funding going into it but we
do need a replacement for the uh the
grant to
support householders because we do need
to really tackle the emissions from
buildings emissions from buildings in
the uk are something like 25 of our our
co2 emissions they really aren't coming
down fast enough for us to meet our net
zero target so this is an absolute
priority for the government
and we you know people need help and
they need to understand what they can do
and of course at the moment replacing
your boiler is a distressed purchase if
your boiler goes um then you desperately
need something particularly if winter's
coming on so you know people need to be
able to plan and we don't know what
support there's going to be at the
moment yeah and time is ticking isn't it
isabella 47 days till cop 26. so what
would you say the government absolutely
must prioritize to credibly host that
climate conference in glasgow
yes as you say only 47 days and yet we
are very
um far off meeting our our net zero
target
however if the
government
committed to the housing and transport
policies that they have put out for
consultation right now we would be a
third of the way to where we need to be
by 2032 which is a significant
amount
um and i think in terms of
the massive delay it has been hugely
disappointing and i think it's made the
environment sector feel a little bit
nervous
but of course you have to think of alec
sharma who's the president of this
summit who's been flying around the
world
negotiating with very big significant
nations trying to ensure that they will
support us in this
ambitious summit and yet we don't have
anything yet to say in terms of what we
are going to do at home yet so we need
to get all of those departments to be
working better together in in short
order well let's move on now to look at
fashion's impact on the climate and as
we were saying earlier primark has
promised to make all of its clothes
using recycled or sustainably sourced
materials but are pledges like this
enough to fix the fast fashion industry
and isabel i'm coming back to you
because i know this is this is your line
of business so is a pledge like this
genuine or is it greenwashing how do we
know
i think anything like this should be
welcomed and i think that the
corporate sector have got a huge part to
play in trying to reduce the impact of
the
fashion industry however it is in it is
incredibly complex you've got the
resource you have the human rights
issues you have the pollution issues
around chemicals and
supply chain mapping is very very
complex for every single retailer
so i think that the government does need
to step in and try and put in some
um producer responsibilities
but of course there's also a lot that we
can do as consumers and just last night
i went to the second-hand
september oxfam
swishing event where everyone bought
their own clothes that they didn't want
to wear anymore and everyone swapped
them it was really fun and we talked
about the fact that actually we didn't
have to spend a lot of money to get new
items whilst recycling others and you
can do this with friends family at work
and i would really
encourage everybody to think more about
shopping online
even oxfam online is such a brilliant
website now it's really it's really easy
to use let me bring let me bring in dame
julia king here you were mentioning
they're wanting the government to
intervene more but and we're a
capitalist economy how far can the
government really be
intervening in these matters and do you
would you advocate something that's like
a fashion equivalent of a sugar tax on
this industry
well i'd i'd like to see more um work
going into
helping people to understand their
carbon footprint and the impact of
things like this we know that young
people are actually very interested in
and very worried about climate change
and actually they can be part of the
change to the kind of slow fashion that
isabella was talking about so the ipcc
and the climate change committee in the
uk
have asked for more climate education
and we have a a new um secretary of
state for education in nadim zahawi just
recently been announced and i think this
is a real challenge for him
is that we should make climate education
absolutely core to the education of
young people in the uk so that people
understand the impact of fast fashion
and so that they can think about whether
that's an appropriate thing for them to
do and actually so that the people who
work in the fast fashion industry can
put pressure on their the companies they
work in to think differently about this
to think about new business models and
different ways of providing us with with
fun and enjoyable clothes that have less
impact on the environment and it's been
good to see you know some of these um
some of these apps starting up where uh
people are being encouraged to um to
sell their second-hand clothes
and give them another life all right
really good to talk to you both tonight
such important issues isabella gornall
dame julia king thank you very much for
your time on sky news that is everything
from us for tonight joining me on the
show tomorrow to discuss all of those
big climate issues will be jen allen
lecturer in international relations at
cardiff university and mohamed ado
director of power shift africa
[Music]
you